[Music]
all right our first mascot is full of
people's crushed dreams that's right
it's the waste basket full of losing
Powerball tickets the waste basket full
of losing Powerball tickets oh very sad
but he's determined you think he can do
it I think he can
[Applause]
tried to get fancy that was amazing you
got fans he's alright he's okay I
thought he was dead
our next mascot is sadly long past his
prime that's right it's the Christmas
tree that wasn't thrown away until
February there he is he's nine brown he
should have been she's been thrown away
a long time ago but he's got a lot of
spunk go Christmas tree
yeah
I got a really unpleasant crotch shot
there
next up he has a little problem but
she's not going to let it interfere with
their relationship just in time for
Valentine's Day it's the couple from an
erectile dysfunction ad how is this even
possible lives in time and I think they
can do it
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay everybody all right there okay Wow
yeah if you thought if you thought that
guy was self-conscious before all right
our next mascot is an iconic NBA
superstar who fell victim to an evil
voodoo Gertz that's right it's Shaquille
O'Neal with a shrunken head
[Applause]
secur
[Applause]
I put that see him to go up oh he has
trouble seeing
that was rough I love that mascot
alright next our next mascots always
incredibly annoying to encounter it's
the ice cube tray that was just just put
in the freezer let's get him out of here
there he is he was just burning this
thin layer of ice this is gonna be a
mess go ice cube tray go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ice cube tray ready to be consoled by
Shaquille O'Neal with a shrunken head
our final mascot is a reenactment of the
iconic prize-winning 1932 photograph of
workers enjoying their lunch while
sitting on a beam suspended high above
New York City I think many of you have
seen this photo before yeah this is a
terrible idea for a mascot please
welcome the iron workers having lunch on
a beam in 1932
is this gonna go
[Applause]
times are tough you can do it Go Go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]